[Music]
seven did he ever address why he didn't
put his daughters
in no I'm asking Ernest I I would I
would say you're getting blown out and
you're coming off everybody playing 40
minutes the night before that happens
all the time in everybody out and well
he I I actually had no problem with him
doing that tonight they were going to
lose that game he did play I didn't know
if he dressed him because he's mad no
they played they played the night before
went to overtime ain't no sense they
wern't going to come back and win the
game I got no problem with has that ever
happened in your life yes of course it
has what when you didn't start the third
quarter as a well they took out they
gave up game we all never happened I've
never seen that have you ever seen that
before uh I don't remember but I like
when the game is over I've gotten taken
out of game you just saw with LeBron and
AD no they got start the third quarter
you just no you just saw LeBron and AD
not taking out the game but it was a
close game when it was a close game for
LeBron in the history of basketball let
me tell you something
go back go back and look at that game
when when the game was over he took ad
and LeBron out they didn't play they
didn't play anymore the history of
basketball well I don't agree with that
I've never you cannot name a time I'm
not talking about I'm talking about
tonight we just saw what happened
tonight with ad and LeBron it was like a
12-point lead at halftime it got to 25
they didn't play again that's not what
he's talking about he said didn't start
the third quarter game was over they
they didn't play 40 minutes the night
before have you ever seen it I don't
know that's why I have no problem with
the tonight if it's never happened in
the history of basketball and you three
of us have seen everything we've either
been part of it been part of it seen it
heard about it and I've never had I've
never seen it at any rate unless they
were mad at you at at any rate Milwaukee
wins at 135 to 102 and look we spent the
entire pregame show talking about the
Milwaukee defense uh oh wait I'm sorry
Ernie cuz I I do because Pat Riley has
said things like like this no or pep Phi
Jackson I'm not calling timeout y'all
put this like I wouldn't allow them to
sit and rest if they put themselves in
that position I agree I that's that's my
point so I would be like no you got to
deal with that you you put yourself in
there I'm not putting these guys out
here yet to let them be embarrassed and
have them come out no you put this
embarrassment on him that's what Phil
Jackson would have done that's what
that's what Pat Riley would have done
that's what Rudy T would that's and
that's that's what I believe with should
have done and I just I disagree those
guys played 40 minutes the night before
an overtime game they were down 30 they
were down 30 at halftime ain't no sense
of putting those guys out there
so